there are three billion billion billion
prochlorococcus in the ocean that's 10
to the 27th or an optimum this Pico
planean is so tiny a drop of seawater
contains 20,000 pizzelle but together
their math adds up to that of 220
million Volkswagen Beetles and they
cover a vast swath of a planet living
between 40 degrees north and 40 degrees
south since their discovery in the 1980s
these ocean-going microbes have opened
up world after world to researchers
helping in to understand microbes ocean
ecosystem even the rise of animals on
the planet though prochlorococcus like
other microbes reproduces by dividing in
half not all of them are genetically
identical instead over time they have
separated into eco type strains that
contain different genes better adapted
to their environment at the surface of
the ocean where nutrients are scarce
highlight adapted prochlorococcus have a
sleek genome of about 1,700 genes and
can still grow on almost pure sea water
carbon dioxide and sunlight in low light
is deep as 200 metres their genomes bulk
up to as much as 2700 genes to help them
capture light and nutrients in a deep
water but there aren't only two eco
types of prochlorococcus there are
thousands each with its own genetic
repertoire so far researchers have
estimated there may be more than 80,000
different genes in the plural Hawkins
collective that's four times affinity as
we have even more abundant than
prochlorococcus are their vesicles these
are tiny membrane bound packets and
contain DNA RNA and proteins there are
spots act in the food source decoys
against viruses and a way of sharing
genes
each prochlorococcus magis two vesicles
we're talking many many more
Volkswagens worth of perchloric rockets
products in the ocean prochlorococcus is
sheer abundance and photosynthetic
talents make it a huge player in ocean
food web and climate recent analysis of
the evolution of their metabolism
suggests that as the genome became more
and more streamlined they lost certain
pathways augment offload carbon and
building up a hospitable environment for
other ocean critters a new research
suggests that if this population grew
and helped fuel the explosion of early
life in the oceans and the rise of
oxygen in the Earth's atmosphere giving
these tiny life-forms a chance to shape
something much bigger
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]